welcome to this video playing martyr
bollocks some major bollocks pan off the
coke are done playing this g6 line the
quite ambitious line to play I think
it's this one right queen bee three now
ya can get to get to this popular
position only recently this rose to
prominence it's been adopted by some
good players black gum sets his help on
the bishops and the square on d5 while
white is hoping from his slightly better
development and the sea bond as a point
of attack so spending quite some time
and only you you play em yeah exactly
that q into c 3 okay
this is a move that at some point is
usually played anyway not sure about the
exact spot but controls the e5 square
like to do like to do that play that
immediately be three
not sure maybe once play a for Bishop e3
maybe a five if I should have tried
maybe they add this a five most might be
a good idea maybe it's still less it
introduces the very simple Bishop before
okay but also maybe after a three and
that's a weakness I can play you can
play on and a5 a4 also would be nice if
I would get rid of the apron who just
ignores it maybe you can just sacrifice
the exchange I'm not dying if you didn't
overlook that I mean a fibers it's very
very obvious it was just combining this
one move threat with the idea to play a
form so ok Mac wind quintet form and
night g5 these ideas
yeah it's dangerous no doubt how to how
to defend Queen f5s one idea but is
maybe can play a d5 d5 is a move that I
would seriously consider clearing d4 for
the night likee takes 90 for this kind
of youth maybe Queenie five then ok
Group C 5 also also possible yeah it
should be 7s ugly ok still don't don't
see what else yeah this is a bit bit of
bit of ugly chassis but it's an exchange
something nothing something to some
material compensation yeah ok I cannot
take this much I understood but is there
something threatened really
I could play a very ambitious movie 85
intending de and then grab ya the smiter
very ambitious could easily be I can
take with the rook wow I have a ten
rupee aid I come on let's do that if
it's not working it's just one game the
basic idea is after taking okay he's
grabbing them
hmm yeah and it's a strong
gasps is that easy why what what an
idiot I am it wasn't necessary at all I
mean I could have played anymore ruki 8
or something and he has compensation but
nothing spectacular I simply cannot take
25 95 and it's it's it's gone is it
the more I think of it i'm not sure we
takes King F 795 checking yet it looks
ridiculous but where's the made 27 I go
look ahead
hmm check aha so um it wasn't that easy
yes but is it term is it winning that
winning for him still not sure check
this may be wins what back yeah yeah I'm
playing with fire
no black resigns I shouldn't I shouldn't
lose any more him but it's it's I mean
it was if I was bad i'm just unnecessary
and tim bhatia don't I don't I think it
should should we have maybe you draw I
mean he certainly has a big attack but I
shouldn't lose I don't think so computer
wants to take it okay i took with the
Queen Queen d6 is a row okay yeah this
losers yeah I'm on a minute I'm going to
admit him yeah if I've was a bad
practical decision I mean no no question
the computer actually gives white the
big edge and says that he awoke g5 is
winning this is very nice very very nice
so I'm so I'm in trouble yet
okay this means that Bishop d7 was bad
so this one problem
something like this it's very tricky to
defend I mean I'm very sure I really
sacrifice the exchange I mean didn't
blunder it it so it is some compensation
that's that this is this is clear maybe
this was was bad i don't know i was i
was afraid of of the Queen move but
maybe I can still play here if he goes
Queen arrived queen and five yeah I
underestimated that one a bit i
overestimated this one a bad [ __ ] so
this was better yeah I did requires some
precision black it's okay it's it's it's
it's a compensation but like it's not
worse but complicated to claim it's
easier for white and blitz only played
this nicely not in the best possible way
but always keeping keeping pressure on
and here I'm already in trouble I mean
this is the successful sir was
interesting but this is just it just
great I'm losing the Queen check very
nicely alright thanks for watching